dany langue merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors le couple
franco-allemand doit convaincre les 25
autres états membres d'adopter le plan
de relance de 750 milliards d'euros de
la commission on le disait on sait que
les pays dits frugaux 1 sont réticents à
l'idée d'une mutualisation de la dette
comme en gala merkel emmanuel macron
vont-ils s'y prendre pour les convaincre
selon vous alors je ne sais pas comment
ils vont s'y prendre pour les convaincre
mais il est suffisamment pas que je
trouve l'initiative de monsieur macro et
madame merkel intéressante pour le
souligner et c'est effectivement après
cette crise des cours des virus il ya un
véritable enjeu avoir en plan de relance
européen 750 milliards c'est sans doute
insuffisant et ont fait face un certain
nombre de pays qui se comme les pays bas
par exemple qui se permettent de nous
donner des leçons alors qu'en fait ils
ne devraient avoir aucune leçon à leur
alloue données du cher et c'est pour
préciser que reproche cpi frugaux
justement dit frigo dans l'est dont les
pays bas c'est des pays qui sont obsédés
par la notion d équilibre budgétaire qui
est une très mauvaise option en économie
qui n'a aucun sens autant quand on est
un ménage effectivement sur l'ensemble
de sa vie il faut respecter un certain
équilibre des dépenses et des recettes
autant pour un état c'est très différent
parce que quand on était à 100 dette
quand sade est arrivée à échéance il
peut toujours se ré endetter est la
vraie question c'est de savoir à quel
taux d'intérêt donc aujourd'hui on a des
taux d'intérêt extrêmement bas voire
négatives pour l'allemagne cette
initiative d'endettement commun au plan
européen est une initiative intéressante
donc ces pays sont à mon avis
complètement décalé ils sont obsédés par
les types budgétaire ils sont obsédés
par l'austérité alors que même par
exemple les pays bas jouent sur la
concurrence fiscale
les pays bas c'est le pays toi même qui
travaillent le moins par semaine 30
heures en moyenne dans
européenne c'est le pays qui a monté une
dette privée complètement délirante est
insoutenable
donc je sais des pays qui sont très mal
placés pour nous donner des leçons et
d'ailleurs 750 milliards c'est sans
doute pas suffisant et c'est sans doute
pas assez ciblées donc faire toute une
histoire sur un plan de 750 milliards
c'est décalé au vu du contexte
économique et social
alors on lisait un plan de relance
historique 750 milliards d'euros
comprenant 500 milliards d'euros de
subventions et de 250 milliards d'euros
de prêts quelles peuvent être les
limites selon vous d'un tel plan de
relance il on a bien vu avec la crise
ils prônent un virus en france que c'est
principalement les grands groupes qui
ont bénéficié des mesures prises
moi je j'ai rencontré énormément de
patrons de petites entreprises aux
restaurateurs et serra qui n'en ont
jamais vu la teneur moi ma crainte c'est
que ces sommes vont être utilisés pour
financer les groupes du cac 40 qui sont
les alliés de monsieur monsieur balcon
où les groupes du dax en allemagne
équivalent qui sont les alliés madame
merkel moi j'ai bien près j'ai bien peur
que l'économie en bas les pme et pmi qui
sont le tissu économique de nos pays
n'en bénéficient pas et par ailleurs
c'est un plan n'est pas ciblé sur la
priorité absolue qui est la transition
écologique
on aurait vraiment besoin d'un plan
européen conséquent substantielle pour
assurer l'isolation des bâtiments pour
assurer le ferroutage pour assurer la
transition écologique qui est urgente
aussi bien au plan économique le plan
climatique donc ce plan est là ce n'est
pas ciblée vers ses priorités qui sont
en extrêmement important est ce qu'on
peut dire aujourd'hui que la vision
d'angela merkel finalement elle a évolué
on peut se souvenir de sa posture face à
l'as à la grèce au moment des dettes
importantes auxquelles devaient faire
face les grecs
oui alors j'ai l'impression que ça
évolue mais là on est on a pu à faire
congrès qui sont censés être des cigales
parce que je pense que le parti d'angela
merkel et moi toujours ainsi on a fait
aux entreprises allemandes et il faut
pas oublier qu'en allemagne
très peu de français savent et en
allemagne avant même l'actrice du
colonel virus vous aviez le grand
patronat allemand et la db qui est le
principal syndicat revendicative de
gauche qui étaient d'accord pour dire
qu'il fallait absolument un plan de
relance en allemagne en particulier au
vu de l'état seulement des astros et des
infrastructures
un quart des ponts et des routes menace
de s'effondrer
donc c'est un peu comme si en france le
medef la cgt se mettaient d'accord pour
demander à monsieur l'accord enfin de
relance c'est pour vous dire à quel
point c'est improbable et donc vous
aviez déjà l'équivalent du medef est
l'équivalent la cgt qui était d'accord
pour demander un plan de relance
conséquents en allemagne pour réparer
les infrastructures et faire repartir le
pays donc ça intervient quand même dans
un contexte où vous aviez comment dire
les partenaires sociaux qui demandait
une infection de cette politique et qui
demandait de rompre avec cette obsession
allemand de l'équipe budgétaire qui est
absurde et qui ne mènent nulle part
c'est une vieille idée 19e siècle qui a
mené un certain nombre de nations au
désastre y compris au moment la crise de
29 dont c'est une idée à laquelle il est
urgent de relancer et si ça permet à
madame merkel et aux allemandes évoluent
et et c'est une très bonne nouvelle
merci beaucoup d'ail langue dany lang
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes économique